let's examine when the momentum of a
system is constant and apply that to
solving problems first we'll revisit the
impulse equation on the Left we have the
impulse the integral of the total
external force acting on a system
between some initial and final times and
on the right we have the change in the
total momentum of the system between
those initial and final times in a
situation where the impulse is zero we
have that the change in the momentum is
zero P initial is equal to P final in
other words the momentum of the system
is constant between some initial and
final time this is a vector equation but
in many problems we can set up our
coordinate system so we only have to
consider one dimension here's a simple
example of one block moving along a
horizontal surface with some initial
velocity colliding with a block at rest
and then the two blocks stick together
and move is momentum constant during
this collision to answer that question
we need to think about what our system
is let's look at the system of both
blocks together we can see the external
forces gravity and the normal force add
up to zero so our total external force
is zero during the collision each block
exerts a force on the other but that is
an internal force if both blocks are
included in our system you can see that
if our system was just one of the two
blocks we would need to know the
collision force in order to solve for
the final speed therefore we will choose
our system to be the two blocks together
we then need to set up a coordinate
system will click the origin here and
this direction to be positive X now we
need to identify the initial and final
States our initial state will be just
before the blocks collide the momentum
of the system is the sum of the momentum
of each block individually we have m1
times v1 initial X
times I hat plus m2 times V to initial X
times I hat this second term is 0 since
block 2 starts at rest the final state
is right after the collision when the
two blocks are moving together they have
the same velocity so the final momentum
is m1 plus m2 times V final x times I
hat this gives us an equation that will
allow us to solve for whatever quantity
we are not given now let's look at a
similar collision one that's happening
in two dimensions if we have one block
coming up from the bottom hitting one
that's coming in from the side I'll
choose my unit vectors to be like this
my origin here the momentum equation
gives us two equations one along the x
direction and the other along the y
direction
once again I'll choose the initial state
to be just before the collision and the
final state to be just after the
collision the momentum in the initial
state is again the sum of the momentum
of each block individually and the
momentum in the final state is the mass
of the two blocks added together times
the velocity of the two blocks
notice that this velocity has a
component in both the X and the y
directions again the total external
force on the system is zero so the
impulse is zero in both the X and y
directions and therefore momentum is
conserved for both the x and y
components so I can write my two
momentum equations like this
the impulse equation is a vector
equation so generically in two
dimensions we will have two equations we
always need to check that the momentum
is conserved in each direction
separately and it is possible to have a
case where momentum is conserved in one
direction but not the other if we have
some net external force in one direction
what would happen if in our 1d collision
example the blocks now experienced
friction along the surface can we still
assume that the momentum is conserved in
fact if we pick a point in time right
before the collision and compare that to
a point in time right after the
collision we can see that the impulse
from friction is such over such a short
period of time that the impulse is
really really small and we can say that
the momentum is approximately constant
if we consider times later after the
collision is over then momentum is
certainly not conserved which is what
you would expect you'll see the two
blocks slowed down due to friction so
even if there are other forces acting on
the system like friction or gravity we
can still calculate the result of a
collision as if the momentum is constant
during the collision by picking times
only a very small delta T apart